hey how you folks doing today I've got
some new information today that I hope
you guys are going to be able to find
just as interesting as I did now that
the holidays are over the game of
thrones production crew has resumed its
filming for the seventh season and
Emilia Clarke was also spotted yesterday
on a flight to Belfast Northern Ireland
and today she actually posted a video on
Instagram and in that video you can see
that she is wearing her blonde wig and
she also revealed that today is their
first day at work at the studios in
Belfast
so my first initial thought after
hearing about the news was I hope they
were filming scenes using CGI with her
and our dragons because I think most of
those scenes are going to be shot
indoors because of the amount of CGI
that they're going to use so I think
when it comes to scenes with her on our
dragons we probably aren't going to see
too many spoiler photos taken while they
are outdoors on set unless it's using
the dragon fire kind of like we got a
few weeks back when they were filming
the scenes where Daenerys is supposed to
attack the Lannister forces after they
sacked Highgarden and I think now that
more of the main cast is in Northern
Ireland it got me excited because I know
that they aren't finished with this set
yet at the Wolf Hill quarry which most
of you have seen in some of my other
videos
this set is supposed to stand in for a
scene taking place north of the wall and
from the plot leaked we know there is
supposed to be a scene where Jon and
company go north of the wall to capture
a wight so he can take it south and
prove to the other Lords that the threat
of the White Walkers is real and that he
needs help to fight them and I think
this white capture scene is supposed to
take place on a frozen lake where Jon
and company gets surrounded by the
night's king and a shitload of whites
but that's when Danny actually shows up
with their dragons and is able to rescue
everyone but Jon but during the rescue
attempt one of her dragons is taken down
by the night's king and turned into a
nice dragon and John is supposed to be
nearly killed but his uncle Benjen shows
up just in time and he sends the injured
Jon off on his horse then that's when
Benjamin is supposed to get swarmed by
the whites then presumably killed and
turned into a full white himself and
thanks to a ton of spoilers we've been
able to start the piece most of this
together which has been leaning toward
this part of the leak
true and we know that this set has a
frozen pawn with the space in the middle
for characters to stand for the scene
where they are surrounded and other
reports came out that it seemed will
indeed have 300 extras being used for
whites then the rest will be digitally
added so we know there will be a ton of
whites on this set where the frozen pawn
is - and the characters that were
supposed to go in its mission have shown
up in Northern Ireland as well like
tormund Jorah John and benjin have all
been seen in this area and John has
actually already been spotted on this
set filming part of the scene which you
can see in his photo and it is pretty
hard to make out who it is but I think
that definitely looks like his man-bun
and the person that took this photo said
it was definitely John and Watchers on
the wall also said that the person who
took the photo is a reliable source so
I'm going to believe this for right now
but the only missing thing from this
leaked scene has been Daenerys Targaryen
that's really the only like last piece
of the puzzle that I need to confirm
that this scene is going to absolutely
take place and I think now that she just
showed up in Northern Ireland and has
been filming in the studios there I
think that's exactly what she's doing
and I also have some other news that
kind of helps back it up a little bit I
got a message from someone who lives a
couple minutes away from the wolf hill
quarry set where this scene is going to
be taking place and he said they have
been filming here at night again now
that the holidays are over he said the
lights from the set light up half of the
mountain and I asked him if he lived
near the set and he said it's only about
five minutes up the road so I asked him
if there were any other details he could
give me and he said he took photos from
the set but can't get near it at night
but he also said that the cast is being
spotted around town like John Snow and
Danny so I thought maybe Danny was just
seen in town because she was there to
film indoors at the Studios but he said
no that Danny has been seen in town near
the wolf hill quarry set to not just in
town where the studios are so just to
try to confirm his story a little bit I
checked his Facebook page just to see if
there was anything on there to back up
anything he is saying and I was kind of
hoping he posted some photos or
something like that but I couldn't
access his photos because we aren't
friends
on air but I could see his personal
information and it does say he lives in
Belfast and I don't feel like he really
has any reason to lie about it so I kind
of would believe him
because he has somebody that I did talk
to you personally so I would tend to
believe him more than I would the leak
and he said he only lives five minutes
away from the set and he said Danny has
been seen near the set so I expect all
this to come true
I definitely think Daenerys is in town
of film at this set and I think in days
to come we will be getting more
information and we will learn that
Daenerys is going to be there with her
dragons to attempt to rescue John and
his team of white hunters she is in
Northern Ireland where all these
exciting scenes are going to be taking
place and filming has resumed so keep
your eyes open for any more spoilers to
come so that's pretty much it guys but I
definitely believe now that Dany is in
Northern Ireland she is going to be
filming with John and Jorah and torment
and the Hound and all the other
characters that are going to be on this
set at the wolf hair quarry this guy
says he lives minutes away and people
I've already been spotting her in town
even though she just got there he said
there's been filming going on right
after the holiday so I definitely think
they're prepping for the major battle
scene right here and I'm I'm pretty
anxious to see what other news comes out
now that everything has resumed so keep
your eyes open guys as soon as I get
some more information I will post it to
you immediately but after having a
conversation with this guy got me very
excited so I just wanted to let you know
what he told me as soon as I could
so thank you guys for listening to this
and comment below and tell me what you
think
do you guys predict all this to come
true as well at least this scene let me
know what you think guys bye